Hi, my name is Lisa
Wray, and I want
to talk to you about
some huge changes we've
made in how notifications work
in the L developer preview.
The changes give
developers tons of options
to make notifications way
better for your users.
Now that they appear front and
center on the L lock screen,
and Android Wear watches,
creating great notifications
is more important than ever.
With the L developer preview, we
introduce Google's new material
design language.
Material design isn't
limited to Android apps.
It also encompasses the system
UI, including notifications.
So here's a notification
screen in Jelly Bean
and another in the
L developer preview.
Notifications are now on a
light background with dark text
and there are also some
typographic and graphic design
changes.
If you've been following our
guidelines since Jelly Bean,
your notifications small
icon should already
be white with alpha.
In L, we expect
this, and we draw it
on top of a circular background
whose color you can customize.
When you add a large it
will turn your small icon,
and it's colored backdrop,
into a badge on the large icon,
rather than sending it over
to the other side of the view,
as in previous releases.
If you're using
Notification.Builder,
or notification compat,
then these changes
are taken care of for you.
And your notification
should display correctly,
on both pre L and
L preview builds.
However, if you're using
custom notifications,
you'll need to
update your layouts
to match the new format.
So we encourage
you to use builder
to make notifications,
if at all possible.
In addition to
visual changes, we've
merged the notification
shade, something
we've in Android since
1.0, with the lock screen.
One of the most
common reasons people
take out and unlock their phones
is to respond to notifications.
Now content is immediately
accessible and interactive.
You can double tap to access or
swipe to dismiss right there.
And as a developer,
you get this for free.
It's the default behavior in L.
Of course, security is something
we take very seriously.
We don't want to expose
anything that should be private.
So we've added visibility
for notifications.
There are three levels.
The first, which is the default
for all existing notifications,
is private, meaning the contents
won't be shown on lock screens.
You can provide a public
version of your content
or the system will make
a generic one for you.
There's also public,
meaning the notification
is always shown, no matter
whether the screen is locked
or not, and secret meaning
if your screen is locked,
then we won't show
the notification
on the lock screen at all.
Users can also enable or disable
their lock screen notifications
completely, and decide if
they want notifications
be kept private or not.
Also new an L are
heads up notifications,
a way for the system UI to
put important information
in front of the user, without
disrupting their activity.
When the screen
is on and unlocked
important notifications
will be automatically shown
as heads up.
For example, notifications
that currently
use a full screen [INAUDIBLE]
or high priority with a sound
or vibration like phone
calls, will become
heads up notifications
while the phone is in use.
After a few seconds,
they slide away,
so you can continue
playing or reading,
and will move into the
notification bar-- for example,
to say call missed,
or alarm snoozing.
And we've had notification
priority since Jelly Bean.
But it's especially
important now
to take a look at your
apps notifications
and classify them appropriately.
Many default priority
notifications
are probably better expressed
as low or minimum priority,
or possibly high priority, if
the message is truly urgent.
We've also added
notification categories.
It's OK not to
specify a category.
But some examples of
top priority messages
that should have one
are incoming calls,
instant messages, or alarms.
And we're fleshing out
notification extras,
which were added in Kit Kat.
In particular, we want to
help you see information
about the people you care about.
So you can add a list
of the people associated
with a notification,
identified by content provider
your eyes, so the Android system
could surface notifications
from your favorite contacts.
And it's especially
important now
that your app use only
the notification features
to play sounds and vibrate.
Please don't work around
the notification manager
to vibrate or play
your own sounds.
With all these options, we've
given users a convenient way
to configure
notifications for any app.
You can add a flag to your
notification settings activity
in the manifest to have it
listed in the app notification
section of the
system settings up.
Also, lock screens in
the L developer preview
no longer show controls for
your remote control client.
Instead, your app can provide
media playback control
from the lock screen
to your notification.
And there's a new media style
template just for this purpose.
Finally, don't forget
the notification options
already available
for Android Wear.
Your app's existing
notifications
automatically transfer
to the watch for free.
But with just a little
bit of extra code,
you can get support for
pages, stacks, voice replies.
Conversely, if you don't
want your app's notifications
on the watch, you can
use set local only true.
And this, like the
new media style,
is available both in
the notification class
and in the support library.
So that's a lot.
What should you, as
an app developer,
go do right now to get your
notifications ready for L?
Use Notification.Builder or
create new layouts for pre
and post L. Pick an accent
color for your notifications,
because that's new.
Decide what visibility you
want your notifications to be.
And if it's not
public, then think
about what you'd like to
show on the lock screen.
Add a flag in the manifest to
get your notification setting
activity listed in
the system settings.
And if you don't have a
notification setting activity,
go make one.
And finally, if you
have notifications,
your app is already
on Android Wear today.
So make sure it's working
the way that you want.
If you don't have a watch
yet, use the emulator.
And you can get started today
with all of these new features
by downloading the Android
L developer preview.
And check out the
docs on notifications
on developer.android.com.
Thanks for watching.